i thought it was more ideological i
thought it was more enlightening in that
at long last you felt like there was a
prime minister's questions where instead
of trading rhetorical blows and
political attacks there were of course
political attacks but it was around
policy and differences over policy and
differences over ideology actually and
so quite straight questions quite
straight answers it was almost going
back to the old dividing lines of the
conservatives
versus labor as liz trust talked about
not wanting to put tax on business and
being a low taxation party that she was
going to hold the line on that she
wasn't going to
just give in to sort of public pressure
for tax rises and kierstama
trying to position her as
someone and a party on the side of
vested interests as he would put it
whereas lay was on the side of working
people now for labour that has been a
difficult uh line to draw under boris
johnson who of course took the red wall
and with brexit did position himself as
a a man who was on the side of working
people against the establishment if you
like you remember the way in which he
somehow quite stout deathly sort of
knitted together two very uh different
parts of the country and he knitted
together the kind of affluent shires of
the southeast as well as parts of the
traditionally working class red wall i
mean some of the things that kierstama
said he said
she's claiming to break orthodoxy but
the reality is she's reheating george
osborne's fell corporation tax plans he
said the conservative party will be
forcing working people to pay the bills
and he said the people who pay the bills
will be the working people of britain
and what is this all about it's about
this huge energy package tomorrow in
which liz truss
will announce we think a freeze or a cap
on wholesale prices of gas that means
that
electricity and energy providers can
pass that on to consumers an effective
cut to your bills we think it could be
capped at about two and a half thousand
pounds that's slightly up from the
freeze of
1971 back in april but it's much cheaper
than the average of three and a half
thousand pounds a year in october that
people are expecting but how will she
pay for it she's going to borrow yeah so
effectively the taxpayer in the long run
has to pay back government borrowing and
kierstama there was very clear he said
you're asking the taxpayer to foot that
bill instead of taxing companies a
windfall tax energy companies with these
excess profits of a prediction of 170
billion a year a year
so in the next couple of years now jane
i know that the conservative party know
that that is controversial to try and
hold that line but ideologically liz
trust genuinely believes that low
taxation on business and not putting
taxes up for business will grow the
economy and she is consistent so this is
going to be
a clear dividing line between the
parties from labour's perspective i was
just talking to someone messaging them
about what they thought about that they
said we're very happy with this it's a
clear dividing line and as far as
they're concerned british people don't
like borrowing going up to fund these
things so liz trust clearly prepared to
do something that's publicly really
unpopular because it's what she believes